salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
vous l'attendiez tous aujourd'hui on
parle de la sauce préférée des Français
la mayonnaise essayez de mélanger de
l'eau et de l'huile vous verrez c'est
impossible et pourtant pour réaliser une
mayonnaise c'est exactement ce que l'on
fait c'est extraordinaire au sens propre
du terme comment est-ce possible
pourquoi la mayonnaise prend-elle allait
suivez moi ça tourne
les Français adorent la mayonnaise
c'est bon deux Français sur trois
affirment consommé au moins une fois par
mois et 60% on aurait en permanence dans
le réfrigérateur il n'est donc pas
étonnant que chaque année Paris soit le
théâtre d'un championnat du monde qui
flirt bon la mayonnaise celui de leur
maillot un plat
iconique des bistrots français sans
surprise le titre est détenu depuis le
14 novembre 2022 par un Chef français
Grégoire Simon de la Grande Brasserie
dans le quatrième arrondissement de
Paris et maintenant je vous explique
comment on fabrique de la mayonnaise
vous allez le voir c'est un véritable
miracle
avez-vous déjà essayé de mélanger de
l'huile et de l'eau
comme vous pouvez le constater l'huile
et l'eau ne se mélange pas l'huile est
hydrophore elle n'aime pas l'eau et
l'eau est lipophobe elle n'aime pas
l'huile très concrètement les molécules
d'eau se lient entre elles les molécules
d'huile aussi mais les molécules d'eau
et les molécules d'huile ne se marient
pas et vous aurez beau avoir
l'impression de les réunir
comme ceci en patientant quelques
instants ces retours à la case départ
les deux liquides sont séparés en
cuisine ça arrive très souvent quand on
fait une vinaigrette sans autre
ingrédients que du vinaigre et de
l'huile c'est ce qu'on appelle une
émulsion instable mais quand on fait une
mayonnaise avec un œuf et de l'huile ça
fonctionne l'huile et l'eau se mélange
bon il y a pas d'eau dans ces
ingrédients dans l'oeuf un œuf est
constitué à 95% d'eau mais pourquoi ça
prend et bien grâce aux 5% restants des
lipoprotéines ce sont elles qui vont
jouer les agents de liaison entre
l'huile et l'eau contenue dans l’œuf en
chimie on parle de tensioactif ou
d'émulsifiant c'est en soi actif sont
des molécules un peu particulières on
les représente souvent comme ceci avec
une tête hydrophile qui aime l'eau donc
une queue l'hypophyse qui aime l'huile
pour que ça marche
toujours à sortir l'oeuvre du
réfrigérateur d'un bon quart d'heure
avant de vous y mettre de sorte qu'il
soit à température ambiante tiens j'en
profite pour ouvrir une petite
parenthèse où faut-il ranger les œufs où
faut-il les stocker dans le
réfrigérateur ou à température ambiante
et bien selon une étude récente de le
FSA l'Autorité européenne de sécurité
des aliments il vaut mieux les stocker
au frais cette précaution limite en
effet la croissance des bactéries et
donc le risque d'infection mais revenons
à notre mayonnaise quand on l'a bat on
fragmente l'huile en petite gouttelettes
pour faciliter les liaisons entre
l'huile et les tensios actifs on se
retrouve donc avec une multitude de
petites gouttelettes d'huile avec tout
autour des tensions actifs et autour une
petite pellicule d'eau l'eau étant
attirée par la tête des molécules c'est
ce qu'on appelle une micelle et bien
dans une mayonnaise il n'y a que ça 2016
[Musique]
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est
recommandé d'utiliser un fouet comme
celui-ci et un grand saladier pour faire
des gestes amples au passage je vous
conseille d'utiliser un saladier en
verre ou en métal les émulsifiants ont
en effet tendance à s'accrocher au
plastique et c'est pas le moment quand
on fait une mayonnaise parfois il arrive
que la mayonnaise et du mal à prendre
pire qu'elle ne prenne pas du tout
ça peut-être à cause de l'oeuf pas assez
frais attention j'ai dit frais pas froid
l’œuf doit être à température je
l'expliquais mais il ne doit pas être
trop vieux plus le temps passe plus les
tensioactives contenues dans le jaune se
dégrade s'il a été pondu trop longtemps
avant son utilisation il n'y en a plus
assez pour réunir l'eau et l'huile tiens
en fait avec quoi préférez-vous déguster
la mayo dites le moi en commentaire et
en fin de vidéo je vous dirai quel est
mon plat maillot préféré
pour faire une mayonnaise on utilise
aussi de la moutarde une bonne cuillère
à quoi ça sert et bien d'abord ça donne
du goût mais pas que la moutarde
contient également des émulsifiants qui
vont faciliter le rapprochement entre
l'huile et l'eau la mayo va prendre plus
facilement mais attention on n'utilise
pas n'importe quel moutarde ces
molécules se trouvent à l'origine dans
la pellicule qui enveloppe les graines
de moutarde or dans la moutarde à
l'ancienne vous le voyez il y a encore
beaucoup de graines qui n'ont pas été
broyées du coup les molécules
émulsifiantes n'ont pas été libérées si
vous utilisez de la moutarde à
l'ancienne vous aurez donc du mal à
faire prendre votre mayonnaise plus de
mal qu'avec une moutarde classique en
plus les petites graines ne sont pas
forcément les bienvenus quand ce que
l'on recherche c'est avant tout
l'homogénéité et l'onctuosité
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
et là il se produit un autre phénomène
intéressant et la mayonnaise prend du
volume on dit quel monte c'est encore un
phénomène lié à l'utilisation de la
moutarde les molécules émulsifiantes se
comportent comme celles avec lesquelles
on fait de la gelée en captant l'eau
contenue dans l'oeuf et l'humidité
contenue dans l'air elle prenne du
volume elle gonfle ce qui fait monter la
mayonnaise
et voilà le travail des centaines de
milliers de gouttes d'huile sont prises
au piège de molécules d'eau qui forment
une fine pellicule tout autour plus le
piège est serré moins les gouttelettes
d'huile peuvent bouger plus la
mayonnaise est ferme
et tiens allez
pour finir
un tour de poivre une pincée de sel et
il pourrait jouer allez on termine avec
un peu d'histoire qui a inventé la mayo
la première trace écrite d'une
mayonnaise telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui date de 1815 elle est signée
du célèbre Antonin Carême celui que l'on
surnomme le roi des chefs et le chef des
rois il parle d'une manière froide
émulsionnée aux jaunes d'oeuf carême a
inventé de nombreuses recettes mais ce
n'est pas lui qui aurait eu l'idée de la
mayonnaise elle aurait été inventée en
1756 durant la guerre de sept ans à
cette époque les armées de Louis XV sont
en guerre contre les Anglais le duc de
Richelieu cherche envahir mâle la
capitale de Minorque une petite île
située en mer Méditerranée au large de
l'Espagne étant la plus à l'est des îles
de l'archipel des Baléares elle a un
rôle stratégique et commercial majeur
pour les deux pays Richelieu remportent
la bataille et pour fêter sa victoire il
organise un banquier pour lequel sont
cuisiniers aurait inventé une sauce
qu'il baptise en l'honneur de la
victoire la mayonnaise qui serait
devenue la mayonnaise avec le temps on
pense aussi que la mayonnaise pourrait
venir de Magnan dans le Lot-et-Garonne
ou peut-être de Bayonne bagnolese ou
bayonnaise ce serait peu à peu
transformé en mayonnaise mais
l’hypothèse la plus probable reste que
la mayonnaise vient de vieux français
moyeux qui signifiait jaune d’œuf avec
le temps la moyenonnaise serait devenue
la mayonnaise alors qu'est-ce que je
vais servir avec cette belle mayonnaise
tout à l'heure je vous ai promis de vous
révéler ce que je préfère déguster avec
la mayo et bien sans hésitation
un œuf dur le maillot j'adore ça il
existe même une association qui défend
ce plat la somme l'Association de
Sauvegarde de l’œuf mayonnaise à
laquelle j'ai l'honneur d'appartenir la
preuve voici ma carte c'est d'ailleurs
cette association qui organise le
championnat du monde de l'œuf Mayo dont
on a parlé en début de vidéo
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu que je vous ai donné envie de
confectionner vous-même votre propre
mayonnaise si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner et à liker n'hésitez pas
non plus à me suggérer d'autres idées de
plats ou de sauce je vous promets
d'autres vidéos tout aussi délicieuses
allez à très bientôt chers epicurieuses
et épicurieux
tu m'as mis
[Musique]